peter thiel gave us talk at the bitcoin
conference he basically said uh we think
esg thinks ccp uh i think that is
probably one of the most powerful things
that anyone has said uh around this
whole issue and in the framing of it and
trying to get across this point of uh
don't allow people to use the virtue
signaling
of esg to create enemies or or to cancel
people etc how do you think about the
esg issue and how do you think that the
bitcoin community should kind of handle
that
yeah i mean i definitely think that
people should follow the money and again
kind of going back to what we mentioned
earlier to question the messaging that's
out there based on who's putting it out
i mean we as a country have really
pushed nuclear power aside and i think
that was because of some of the
narratives that were out there and it's
really sad because we could harness that
kind of power we need energy energy is
not bad i think we've demonized some
words in in our in our culture and in
our society today that don't need to be
demonized and it's you know i think that
it has had an impact on what's happening
in the russia ukraine crisis as we see
how badly we need this type of
infrastructure and i i just i hope that
people look into these esg narratives
it's the one thing that i'm most
probably concerned about when it comes
to the cbdc's when they program central
bank digital currencies and decide hey
we maybe will give you an incentive to
spend money with companies that are esg
or something you know pet projects that
the government really likes it's like
well people should have freedom to
choose and there shouldn't be these
kind of skewed manipulated incentive
structures based on these government
narratives that may or may not be true i
i question the science that the
government believes in uh and i'm sure
many of us do who who are in bitcoin so
um i thought his speech was really
interesting there were some you know
good parts and bad parts too with
regards to him talking about ethereum i
think being currency uh and bitcoin
being gold uh but you know i just i'm
really bullish on this whole industry
and i hope that
bitcoin helps educate people on energy
in general and this economy that we're
creating and incentivizing in terms of
green energy through bitcoin mining hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time